I'm not going to do a presentation on a
type of integral I guess if you if you
have this in your toolkit and actually
you have it beyond kind of the exam on
this type of integral and you actually
keep it and you retain it then you I
think will become an integration jock
but anyway let me show you what I'm
talking about so let's just remember
what the product rule of differentiation
was so let's say I had two functions
let's say f of X times G of X f of X
times G of X and I wanted to take the
derivative of this so I take the
derivative of f of X times G of X well
the chain rule just told us that this is
just the same thing as let's say the
derivative of the first function f prime
of X times the second function G of X
plus now the first function f of X times
the derivative of the second function
and I'll show you where I'm going with
this in a second now if we were to
integrate both sides of this equation
right because I mean we're still doing
algebra on some levels but everything
you do to one side of the equation you
can have to do the other so if we were
to integrate both sides well if you
integrate this side you're taking the
integral integral of a derivative you
can just get back to what you took the
derivative originally of so this just
becomes f of X times G of X and then we
have to integrate the right hand side
well that just becomes and we're doing
the indefinite integral kind of the
antiderivative but we can use this tool
when you do definite integrals as well
so that's the integral of F prime of X G
of X DX
plus the integral of f of X G prime of X
D of X and now I this might seem a
little bit arbitrary and it is a little
bit arbitrary let me let me take well I
could take either of these but let me
just take I don't know let me take this
one and and move it to the side of the
equation so I'm going to subtract this
term from both sides of this equation
and so we could say this so let me let
me change colors because this could get
confusing this this term right here we
could say that term f of X f of X G
prime of X D of X is equal to this term
let me switch back to the yellow is
equal to f of X G of X minus this term
right because I put it onto this side of
the equation so minus this term minus F
prime of X G of X so what did I just do
it looks like I just well I am just
essentially playing with the product
rule from differentiation that's all I
did and you're probably wondering well
Sal this is all nice and it looks fancy
but what is what what good is this going
to do me well this what I essentially
just did is I kind of proved this you
can call this a formula but I often
forget it especially once I haven't done
it a long time and then I actually just
reprove it to myself just by remembering
the product rule but this is called
integration by parts and I'll show you
where this is useful let's say we want
to take the indefinite integral of let's
say we want to take the indefinite
integral of I don't know X cosine of X
d of X well everything we have in our
integration toolkit so far I don't think
helps us here right because we don't
have a function and it's derivative so
we can't do you know substitution or
which is the same thing as a reverse
chain rule this isn't a simple
polynomial so if you kind of encounter
this when you're when you're doing
integrals kind of the the last toolkit
and this is pretty sophisticated is to
do integration by parts and so how can
we use this for integration by parts
well integration by parts tells us that
if we have an integral where we have a
function and then the derivative of
another function then we could use this
formula to hopefully simplify it so what
I'm going to do and you might view this
as well Sal how did you know to do this
and I'll tell you my thought process
actually after I show you what I did
let's we always in math in general you
always want to simplify you always want
to move from something that's
complicated to something that's simpler
so in this situation if we could assume
that X is f of X and we could assume
that G prime of X is cosine of X or we
could assume the other way around the
reason why I'm going to assume that X is
f of X and I'm going to assume G prime
of X is cosine of X is because later we
want to take the derivative of f of X
and the derivative of f of X simplifies
things a lot and we also want to take
the integral of G prime of X right or
the we want to take the antiderivative
of G prime of X and the antiderivative
of cosine of X is sine of X which is
just as complicated it's not making it
any more complicated and actually I try
it the other way around and you'll see
that if you took the antiderivative of X
you get something that's more
complicated you get x squared over 2 so
that's the intuition and let me just
solve to it and hopefully it'll it'll
make a little bit more sense so if I
assume that f of X is X and G prime of X
is cosine of X then f of X right this
yellow term let me write it in yellow
just for fun so f of X so I'm saying
that f of X is X right f of X is X so
that's X
and let's say G of X is cosine of X
right I'm sorry
G prime of X is cosine of X so the
derivative of G of X is cosine of X so
what's G of X and what's the
antiderivative of cosine of X so that's
sine of X I hope you understand what I'm
saying I this can be a little confused
let me let me write it separately here i
G well I'm running out of space but I'll
write in the corner right down here see
I'm saying that f of X is X and I'm
saying that G of X is sine of X right
and the reason why I knew G of X is sine
of X is because I set the derivative
that I said G prime of X is cosine of X
right so any you know if the functions
if the derivative of a function is
cosine then we know the function itself
is sine right that's just something you
memorize I haven't proven it to you yet
Britain usually in the inside cover of
your calculus book but let's just move
forward and then this is minus the
integral of the derivative of f of X
well what's the derivative of f of X so
we said f of X is X right so the
derivative is just 1 times G of X well I
already said the G of X is sine of X
sine of X and I think you would agree
that we've now simplified this a good
bit because this is just the integral of
sine of X right so this is just equal to
X sine of X right this is just this
first term right here - and what's the
integral of sine of X well the
derivative the derivative of let me make
it even simpler
well we can make this a minus right we
can make this a minus sine of X and make
this a plus right and now it's really
easy what's the antiderivative of minus
sine of X we can ignore this one what's
the antiderivative of minus sine of X
well yeah it's just cosine of X and and
and we should never forget plus C so we
just used the product rule to derive
this formula for integration by parts
and then a lot of calculus books they do
this
you know U and V and DVD this is the
same exact thing I like this more
because it's in it well it naturally
makes more sense to me it's easier for
me to read and I can derive at any time
just from the product rule so I don't
have to necessarily memorize it you
might want to memorize it for the exam
because it's faster when you take the AP
exam but when you do calculus I don't
know it's been about 15 years since I
learned it and I just remember well
integration by parts is just really a
derivation of touch of the product rule
and that gets me back to the format I
don't even have to look it up and then I
can use it so that's the introduction to
the integration by parts in the next
presentation I will do a bunch of
examples well as many as I can fit into
10 minutes of actually using integration
by parts to to solve fairly fancy
integrals I'll see you in the next
presentation